يكون لدينا علاقه طيبه ومميزه مع ايران
مزدهره تنمو لدينا مصالح فيها لديهم مصالح
الذين مصالح فيها لديهم مصالح المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
لزياده الانتاج لن يكون لدى المملكه اي
قدره اضافيه لزياده الانتاج
اعداء وهذا ما حدث مع ملوك النفط جاره
تجمعهما اتفاقات وجذور عميقه اتفقا على
معاداه ايران واختلف لنفس السبب شعبه ما
يتمتع باموال تتحول الى اسلحه عند شعوب
اخرى واليوم تحولت الصداقه الى عداء صريحه
وحرب تكسير عظام الفائز فيها سيكون
كالمهزول ما هو سر العداء القائم بين
السعوديه والامارات وما هو دور امريكا في
اشعال فتيل الازمه بينهما وكيف وجد البيت
الابيض ان ما فعله سيرتد الى وجهه مره
اخرى لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع
الفيديو للنهايه
الخضوع واما الدمار
يبدو ان اخراج ابناء العمسه من الشرق
الاوسط سيكون كخلع الاظافر الطويله
المغروسه في الجلد لابد ان تاخذ معها قطعه
من اللحم وتجرح الجسد فمنذ ايام فجرت
صحيفه
ونشرت تفاصيل اجتماع سري دار بين ولي
العهد السعودي ومعاونيه وقالت الصحيفه
اجتمع ولي عهد السعوديه سرا في ديسمبر
الماضي بمعاونين كان ابن سلمان يستشيطوا
غضبا من الامارات وقال لقد طعنون غدرا في
الظهر ولكننا لم نصمت فقد ارسلت لهم قائمه
بطلبات عليهم تنفيذها دون اعتراض وان
رفضوا فساريهم ما يمكنني فعله سافعل بهم
اكثر مما فعلت بقطر ويقصد هنا حصاره
الخالق للدوحه وقيادته عام 2017 لقطيعه
عربيه لقطر ولكن ما هو سبب بين ملوك الذهب
الاسود اليوم
الملاكمه السياسيه دعني اقول لك ان اسوا
ما في هذا الصراع هو ان كلا الطرفين
يستشيط غضبا من الاخر ففي نوفمبر الماضي
فرضت الرياض كلمتها على منظمه اوبك
واجبرتها على تخفيض انتاجها من النفط من
ياتي القرار على هواء زايد واعترض قائلا
لا داعي لتقليل انتاج النفط قرار كهذا
سيغضب الامريكان ما في موقف حلفاء روسيا
ربما يكون رد فعل واشنطن اسوا مما نظن
ليرد بن سلمان لا يهمني غضب واشنطن او
رضاها اليوم ماذا اخذنا من صداقتنا مع
الامريكان ليفعلوا ما يفعلون للواله
الاولى قد يبدو ابن سلمان كمعارض شرس
لهيمنه واشنطن بينما تقول الاحداث انه لم
يكن ليفعل هذا الا باستقبائه بالدب الروسي
والتنين الصيني ويعلم جيدا ان امريكا
يستطيع فعل شيء معه ما دام موجودا في صف
موسكو وبكين ترسل ابوظبي مبعوثها الى بلاد
العم سام لابلاغهم انهم غير راضين عن موقف
السعوديه وكانهم يقولون لها نحن لسنا ضدكم
بل معكم وجودنا في صف السعوديه ليس
برغبتنا فاذا غضبتم من المملكه فنرجو ان
لا تغضبوا منا يا الهي ماذا يمكن ان يطلق
على موقف كهذا اما ما يغضب محمد بن زايد
هو التقارب السعودي مع الحوثيين وعلاقه
المملكه الجديده بايران ففي الطريق بن
سلمان لتطبيق سياسه صفر خلافات التي اشار
بها عليه الحكيم الصيني
ارسلت المملكه وفودا الى الحوثيين في
اليمن لانهاء الحرب معهم وجاءت القشه التي
قسم الدار البعير عندما اخذت الرياض طهران
بالاحضان والقبولات واصبح عدو الامس
المشترك بينهما
اليوم الحميم لاحداهما فقط بالطبع يغضب
هذا الامارات التي لا تزال تعتبر ايران
عدوها الاول والخطر الحقيقي الذي يحدق
بامنها ولابد من الاستقواء عليهم بضباع
واشنطن خصوصا وان ما فعلته المملكه لم يكن
باشراكها فيه او حتى بالتنسيق معها اسباب
عديده صنعت شرخا عميقا في جدار العلاقات
بين بن سلمان وابن زايد ولكن دعني اخبرك
يا عزيزي ان كل ما سمعته هو اسباب ظاهريه
فما هو السبب الحقيقي اذا كرسي العرش انه
الهدف الحقيقي الذي اخفاه بن سلمان وابن
زيد وفضحته الصحيفه الامريكيه والتي نشرت
قائله الخلاف بين الرياض وابو ظبي اساسه
المنافسه على من سيكون صاحب القوى
الجيوسياسيه والاقتصاديه التي سيحكم بها
منطقه الخليج والشرق الاوسط كلها افراد
العائله المالكه الذين صعدوا الى راس
الهرم العربي
يتنفسون الان على من يسيطر على الكره في
الشرق الاوسط بعد غياب امريكا من المشهد
ولكن قمه الهرم ضيقه جدا ولا تتسع الا
لشخص واحد بالطبع لا يقلق ابن سلمان ولا
ابن زيد على كرسي الحكم في بلادهما ولكن
كرسي عرش المنطقه شيء اخر ذلك الكرسي
الذهبي اللامع الذي كانت تجلس عليه ضباع
واشنطن قبل الانقلابات الجيوسيوسيه وصفعات
الدب الروسي والتنين الصيني التي اضعفت من
تحكم البيت الابيض في المنطقه كثيرا والان
اصبح كرسي عرش المنطقه شاغرا والكل يحلم
بالجلوس عليه ليكون الحاكم الاقوى لبحر
الذهب الاسود بن زايد يعلنها بلادنا هي
مكان لاكبر تجمع لكبرى الشركات
اقتصادنا سيصبح رقم واحد في المنطقه كلها
نحن احق بكرسي العرش من اي احد اخر ليرد
ابن سلمان بضربه قويه ويصدم غريمه قائلا
اي شركه عالميه كبرى تريد مكانا لها عندنا
فلن نسمح بان يكون مجرد فرع عادي لا بد ان
يكون المقر الاقليمي لتلك الشركه في
المملكه والا لن تطا منتجاتها اراضينا بن
زايد يشعر بالخطر السعوديه تعتبر اقوى
اقتصاد بين العرب وشرطه هذا يعني اضعاف
اقتصاد ابو ظبي فشركات الكبرى لن تسمح
بعدم وجود قدم لا في السعوديه وان خضعوا
لشروط المملكه فستكون الامارات هي اولا
خاسرين لم يكن الصراع بين ملوك النفط
سياسيا فقط فحتى في الرياضه العالميه كانت
الامارات تفتخر بامتلاكها لاحد اقوى انديه
الدوري الانجليزي وهو مانشستر سيتي ولكن
ابن سلمان اعلنها هيهات لن نترك لكم مجالا
فارغا وسيكون طريقكم مليئا بالاشواك فقد
قامت السعوديه بشراء نادي نيوكاسل
الانجليزي وهو نادي قوي وفي نفس الدوري
الذي يلعب فيه النادي الذي تمتلكه
الامارات باختصار يا عزيزي كل مكان تطاؤه
قدم لبن زايد ستزاحمها فيه قدم لبن سلمان
وقد يبدو لك ظاهريا واشنطن سعيده بهذا
الشرخ بين اكبر اقتصادين في الخليج خصوصا
وانها على وشك الخروج من اللعبه نهائيا
ولكن هل واشنطن سعيده بالفعل مصلحه الفتى
المدلل
ربما تندهش يا عزيزي اذا قلت لك ان الجو
بايدن منزعج كثيرا ويتمنى اصلاح ذلك الشرخ
اليوم قبل غدا فابناء العام سامي يرون ان
وجود حاله من العداء بين ملوك الذهب
الاسود ليست في مصلحه اسرائيل فتى واشنطن
المدلل ذلك لان هذا العداء حتما سيقف ضد
اي توسع تريد امريكا الاتفاقيات التي دخلت
بموجبها الامارات والبحرين والمغرب دفعه
واحده في مصيده تطبيع العلاقات مع اسرائيل
وبالطبع يحلم بيض بفتح القوس واضافه دول
قويه اخرى لتلك الاتفاقيات وليحدث ذلك
لابد من وجود توافق بين اقوى دول الخليج
والشرق الاوسط فالعاده قد يجعل تلك الدول
تقف في وجه بعضها البعض وتعطل اي اتفاق
برعايه امريكيه خصوصا اذا كان هذا الاتفاق
يصب في مصلحته اسرائيل
سؤال لكم مشاهدينا من سيفوز بكرسي عرش
المنطقه في النهايه هل هي السعوديه امارات
ام ان الضباع واشنطن يترقبون اي فرصه
سانحه بازاحه الدولتين واسترداد الكرسي
مره اخرى اخبرونا في صندوق التعليقات
[موسيقى]